[Musique]
bonjour Dans auditions publiques tous
les lundis une heure un invité sur LCP
public Sénas soyez bien sur les
bienvenus ce soir un fidèle d'Édouard
Philippe le député de Corse du Sud
Laurent Marc Angélil bienvenue à vous
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
chef du groupe horizon patron du groupe
président du groupe horizon l'assemblée
du nom du parti créé par l'ancien
Premier ministre demain 31 janvier leur
marque angélique deuxième test pour les
anti-retraite leur nombre enflent dans
les sondages d'opinion pourquoi le
gouvernement a-t-il raté sa
communication sur cette réforme cette
réforme est-elle mal partie et les
abeilles Bormes réaffirme que les 64 ans
ne sont pas négociables fait-elle du
Juppé droite dans les bottes Franck
Riester ici même la semaine dernière à
admis que la réforme pénaliserait un peu
les femmes a-t-il eu raison de le dire
et que faire pour rectifier le tir
certains de vos députés se disent
réservés ils vont te rendre compte
éventuellement et fragiliseront la
majorité et prendront ce
toutes ces questions on va vous les
poser dans un instant Brigitte bouché et
Tam traduit vous interrogeront sur le
fond du texte Yves Traa reviendra sur
les ambitions d'horizons et d'Edouard
Philippe loyal est libre surtout libre
vous nous le direz Vincent roux les
questions d'actualité en direct du Fier
live et puis vous avez accepté on vous
en remercie de débattre avec le sénateur
Europe Écologie Les Verts dessus
notamment de la politique nucléaire déjà
deux questions très différentes pour
nous mettre en bouche si vous le voulez
bien Isabelle borne hier a déclaré qu'il
n'y aurait pas de négociation sur le
passage à 64 ans le gouvernement affiche
sa détermination est-ce que c'est
logique est-ce qu'elle a eu raison la
première liste de le dire maintenant et
de le dire tout court
le départ 64 ans c'est le cœur de la
réforme cette réforme elle est assise
sur une volonté une volonté forte du
gouvernement et de la majorité celle
d'assurer la pérennité de notre système
et depuis le début la majorité le
gouvernement nous disons une chose c'est
que pour plus de solidarité entre les
générations pour assurer la pérennité du
système il faudra travailler plus
longtemps et nous étions partis sur 65
ans je le rappelle puisque pendant la
campagne électorale on a évoqué cet âge
et déjà une première concession d'une
certaine manière a été faite en évoquant
plutôt 64
la première concession des deux est-ce
qu'il pourrait tient la voix est-ce que
vous souhaiteriez que ce soit quand même
une hypothèse de travail non moi je
pense que sur
l'âge de départ je crois que c'est un
prérequis pour assurer la pérennité du
système et que l'âge de 64 ans doit pas
être touché on verra quel est le degré
de votre sérénité par rapport au texte
que vous souhaitez évidemment voir
évoluer j'ai une autre question d'une
autre nature un article demande a mis la
semaine dernière les pieds dans le plat
d'une question délicate c'est la maladie
dont souffre Édouard Philippe l'alopécie
qui selon certains dans la classe
politique pourrait constituer un frein
aux ambitions présidentielles d'Édouard
Philippe est-ce que vous partagez cette
préoccupation et est-ce que en parler
c'est déjà nuire à Edouard Philippe non
puisque je parle dans cet article et je
dis quelque chose de très précis en ce
qui me concerne lorsque je vote pour un
candidat ou une candidate à l'élection
présidentielle ce qui m'intéresse ce
sont deux choses ces capacités physiques
parce qu'on le sait c'est un métier
difficile d'être président de la
République et ses capacités
intellectuelles
et bien écoutez lorsque je vois Édouard
Philippe je suis rassuré par ses
capacités physiques et par ses capacités
intellectuelles ça vous arrive d'en
parler parce que
dans ce papier qui insiste et finalement
qui lève un peu le voile sur cette
question que pouvait se poser les
Français il est dit que il n'en parle
jamais alors peut-être il pensait
toujours n'en parlait jamais est-ce que
vous avez des échanges avec lui est-ce
que vous avez justement vous aussi
évoquez mis sur la table et puis après
on en parle plus mais est-ce que ça a
été évoqué
chez vos confrères du point il y a
quelques semaines et je le reconnais
bien dans la manière qu'il a eu
d'évoquer cela c'est pas un sujet tabou
en style le concerne est-ce que vous
craignez la mobilisation de demain
monsieur Marc angélique quand on fait de
la politique il faut pas craindre les
mobilisations mais en revanche il faut
le respecter il y a un droit de
manifester dans ce pays il faut pas le
minorer il faut pas le toiser il faut
écouter ce qui est dit et j'espère que
ça se passera bien notamment au niveau
de la sécurité publique et de l'ordre le
droit de manifester en France il est
encadré mais il doit être respecté
vous craignez des débordements on les
craint tout ça c'est très bien passé la
première journée c'est ce que j'ai
remarqué quelques débordements mais très
très marginaux non mais je remarque que
les organisations syndicales ont bien
organisé les manifestations il y a 15
jours et souhaite que à cela continue de
se passer ainsi parce qu'il en va je le
pense de la sérénité du pays après
craindre naturellement nous avons connu
tout de même notamment en 2018 avec les
gilets jaunes et puis même avant je me
souviens de la loi el khomri en 2016 qui
avait donné lieu tout de même à des
affrontements en plein Paris qui étaient
assez violents des des grèves qui
tournaient mal des manifestations qui
tournaient mal et je crois qu'il en va
de la responsabilité tout à chacun des
organisations syndicales qui organisent
la sécurité autour de ces événements du
gouvernement aussi du ministère de
l'intérieur des policiers qui sont sur
le terrain mais moi j'ai bon espoir pour
que les manifestations se déroulent dans
de bonnes conditions avec des
revendications syndicales des gens qui
se parlaient pour s'exprimer on va en
parler avec Brigitte boucher bonsoir
bonsoir oui parce qu'il y a une
différence avec la manifestation du 19
janvier c'est qu'il y a cette note des
renseignements qui a fuité dans Le
Parisien et qui parle mais justement
d'une radicalisation du mouvement est-ce
que c'est pas en train de changer de
nature avec une gauche radicalisée plus
forte et puis aussi les gilets jaunes
qui pourraient être présent demain ce
que j'appelle de mes vœux c'est que les
manifestations se déroulent dans de
bonnes conditions je viens de le dire
pourquoi parce que d'abord je pense
sincèrement que la cause serait mal
défendue si demain elle était à prise en
otage par ceux qui cassent ceux qui
détruisent les biens publics ce qui
avons à faire le coup de poing contre
les forces de l'ordre deuxième chose
parce que tout simplement en tant que
parlementaire je souhaite qu'il y a un
débat et le débat il doit se dérouler
avec les organisations syndicales et je
l'espère demain dans l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée nationale ça a commencé à en
commission ce matin et j'espère que ça
continuera jusqu'au terme de l'examen de
la loi et si il y a plus de monde que le
19 janvier si on est à plus d'un million
on était entre 1 et 2 millions mais
encore supérieur comment le message doit
être reçu par le gouvernement est-ce que
le gouvernement doit en tirer des
conclusions et lesquelles toujours tenir
compte des manifestations et de la
mobilisation des gens dans la rue
lorsqu'il y a une réforme qui est
contestée qui pose question ça c'est un
peu la langue
d'abord je rappelle que le texte peut
évoluer il va avoir un débat
parlementaire il a commencé aujourd'hui
en commission
parlementaire sont pas dans une bulle
fermée du reste du monde nous vivons
avec nos concitoyens nous échangeons
avec avec eux nous regardons de près ce
qui se passe notamment dans ces
manifestations à Paris mais également en
province nous y sommes sensibles vous
dire que pour vous ça joue vous dans
votre façon d'aborder le texte si vous
voyez qu'il y a beaucoup de monde
rassemblés demain bien vous serez plus
fort dans la façon dont vous voudrez
porter des amendements je crois qu'il
faut prendre en compte ce que nous
disent les gens c'est quelque chose qui
peut paraître très simple mais qui en
même temps très compliqué nous avons des
objectifs dans cette loi à la première
ministre l'a rappelé
c'est assuré la pérennité du système
comment assurer la pérennité du système
c'est pas en baissant les pensions c'est
pas en augmentant les cotisations le
choix qui a été fait c'est celui de
travailler plus longtemps travailler
jusqu'à 64 ans et à ce fameux âge 64 ans
qui pose problème intransigeante
là-dessus elle met peut-être un peu de
l'huile sur le feu avant la journée de
mobilisation je dirais que au moins nous
savons que nous avons une Première
Ministre qui a les idées claires mais
qui peut également discuter sur un autre
sujet sur d'autres sujets qui sont sur
la table et on verra très bien je le
pense dans le cadre de l'examen de la
loi que des co-constructions sont
possibles avec la majorité avec les
oppositions
elle a pas crispé quand même un peu
juste sur la forme sur la façon est-ce
que c'était absolument indispensable de
poser ce pré ce préalable avant même la
manifestation je vous disais tout à
l'heure que encore une fois c'est un
choix qui a est assis sur un constat sur
la forme pardon sur la forme écouter que
ça soit pris effectivement pour une
forme à titre personnel je trouve
beaucoup moins crispants la première
ministre lorsqu'elle dit le cap qu'elle
se fixe que des députés qui disent qu'on
va transformer les missy-clan Z qui
parle de Verdun
quand on évoque l'article 7
dans le débat
en matière de brutalité je crois que
dans les oppositions on a plutôt des
leçons à prendre plutôt cantonnées vous
vous dites que vous allez écouter la rue
qu'il faut que ce texte peut évoluer au
Parlement ça veut dire que pour vous en
l'état il est pas parfait il est
toujours perfectible le texte toujours
on le voit bien parce que il suscite des
interrogations et puis en avançant les
parlementaires soulève un certain nombre
de sujets et nous sommes aujourd'hui à
la veille d'un débat législatif qui peut
très bien
amener à améliorer le texte par la voix
d'amendement déposée par la majorité une
quarantaine 14
amendements groupes après vous avez les
députés qui peuvent bénéficier de leurs
droits amender individuel donc voilà il
y a un débat à avoir et ensuite
l'assemblée souveraine des libres alors
on sait que là il y a la pression de la
rue on sait que la première ministre
elle a dit que les 64 ans n'étaient pas
négociables est-ce que vous pouvez
est-ce que vous devez bouger sur la
durée de pour les carrières longues
parce qu'on sait que ça c'est un point
qui est dur on sait que c'est demandé
aussi par un certain nombre de
manifestants c'est à dire que ceux qui
ont travaillé à 18 19 ou 20 ans par
exemple est-ce que eux devraient faire
43 ans est-ce que ça vous paraîtrait
juste comme tout le monde c'est un sujet
qui est posé par de nombreux députés qui
ont déposé des amendements allant dans
le sens mais vous qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez je pense que ça fait partie je
crois que ça fait partie des discussions
qui doivent avoir lieu dans le cadre de
l'examen de ce texte au Parlement et je
pense que il faudra tenir compte d'un
certain nombre d'avis notamment ceux de
députés y compris même de la majorité et
personnellement vous y êtes favorable au
fait que ils doivent faire le même
nombre d'amnités que le reste des
Français
c'est que il sera indispensable
d'assurer la pérennité du système vous
savez que le coût de cette mesure est de
1,9 milliards d'euros par an
et c'est avant tout en argumentant sur
ce coup que le gouvernement pour
l'instant a dit qu'il ne souhaitait pas
c'est à cela
la même chose pour tous d'apporter une
solution de financement que chaque
amendement qui pourrait coûter davantage
soit
financéabilité la Constitution le
prévoit son article 40 normalement c'est
à dire que c'est pas forcément député
d'apporter la solution tout à fait mais
encore une fois je rappelle que c'est
pas par plaisir aujourd'hui que nous
sommes rentrés dans ce débat nous sommes
rentrés dans ce débat parce que nous
sommes aujourd'hui devant un problème
d'équilibre financier à court terme pas
à long terme comme je peux l'entendre de
si ou de là c'est un problème qui est
urgent qu'il faut régler et ce problème
nous avons décidé de le régler en
travaillant plus pas en baissant les
pensions pas en augmentant les
cotisations et on n'a pas voulu changer
le système par répartition parce que je
le rappelle quand même pour celles et
ceux qui nous écoutent je me suis aperçu
en discutant avec celles et ceux que je
croise dans la rue les Français sont
assez mal informés sur leur système de
retraite il pense cotiser pour eux-mêmes
alors qu'en réalité sur leur feuille de
paye la cotisation elle est pour ceux
qui sont déjà à la retraite c'est un
système qui a été créé en 1945 et qui a
été créé à une époque où vous aviez
trois travailleurs pour un retraité
aujourd'hui on a 1,7 travailleurs pour
un retraité et vu le taux de natalité
française vu le fait que la durée de vie
moyenne s'allonge je crois que nous
allons un moment ou un autre avoir un
gros problème de financement il passe
par plus de travail plus de solidité
et notamment pour meilleure prise en
compte de la maternité des femmes est-ce
que vous pensez qu'il faut qu'elle
puisse déroger à cet âge légal de 64 ans
si elles ont tout leur trimestres grâce
à leurs enfants je pense qu'il faut
d'abord tordre le coup à un certain
nombre d'idées reçues que j'ai entendu
grâce à cette réforme les femmes
travailleront moins longtemps
qu'aujourd'hui c'est une des avancées un
des progrès
à partir de celle qui sont nées à partir
de 1962 je peux vous dire que la courbe
va s'inverser vous avez aujourd'hui
globalement les femmes qui travaillent
plus longtemps que les hommes sur les
courbes dont j'ai aujourd'hui la lecture
et à partir de la réforme pour les
femmes nées en 1962-1963 elle
travailleront moins longtemps elles ont
moins le bénéfice de leur congé
maternité des trimestres qui sont acquis
par les congés maternité ce qui
proposait d'ailleurs par certains
abonnements de la majorité du groupe
moderne mais également du groupe horizon
c'est de prendre en compte ce petit
défaut et de pouvoir je dirais faire
plutôt à la retraite c'est-à-dire avant
64 ans ou c'est qu'elle serait moins
pénalisée c'est-à-dire que elles
auraient une décote moins importante sur
leur pension
je pense que les deux options sont
possibles il y a des amendements qui
vont dans le sens de la deuxième option
que vous avez définie et la première
ensuite c'est dans le cadre d'une
négociation d'une discussion avec le
gouvernement que le Parlement peut avoir
vous savez sur d'autres textes vous avez
eu des discussions entre les groupes de
la majorité le gouvernement là en plus
vous avez un groupe qui a priori qui est
les républicains annoncés qu'il a
souhaité voter la loi il doit y avoir
des discussions après si vous êtes dans
l'opposition ferme basique les
républicains c'est de pouvoir déroger à
cet âge légal de 64 ans finalement quand
on a tous les trimestres comme c'est
dans la loi aujourd'hui ça fera partie
je le pense des amendements qui seront
discutés et qui susciteront l'intéresse
actuelle quand même que d'avoir fait
cela c'est comme toutes les mères de
famille c'est pas un petit défaut je
vous ai dit que le texte était
perfectible je crois qu'il faut avoir
beaucoup d'humilité vous savez le
système de retraite en France il est
complexe et lorsque vous opérer à une
réforme il peut parfois arriver à que
certains paramètres échappent
ça parfois notamment les 44 annuités
avaient à 20 ans on se dit mais mais la
réalité difficile et vous savez aussi
bien que moi que faire des réformes
aussi complexes
ça implique aussi un travail et c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs que nos institutions
sont bien faites sinon le gouvernement
n'aurait pas à présenter des textes
devant l'Assemblée et cette assemblée
dans des libéraires repas et ce serait à
le fait du prince qui l'emporterait il y
a un autre sujet majeur dans cette
réforme des retraites c'est la question
de l'emploi des seniors quelle mesure
coercitives êtes-vous prêt à prendre
pour et bien favoriser l'emploi des
seniors alors vous savez bien on est
aussi confronté à un problème d'ordre
constitutionnel sur un certain nombre de
sujets pour une bonne et simple raison
c'est que nous sommes sur un projet de
loi de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale et que il y a un
certain nombre de mesures qui pourraient
être sanctionné par le Conseil
constitutionnel si on les mettait dans
le texte parce qu'elles ne correspondent
pas à un texte financier ce qui a été
dit n'aurait donc pu faire une réforme
des retraites en tant que tel ça
n'aurait pas posé ce problème je vous
rappelle que je soutiens un homme qui a
été premier ministre et qui a fait ainsi
en 2019
plutôt qu'un projet de financement
il a été annoncé où il sera encore plus
confirmé que un autre texte traitera
très probablement de projet de loi qui
doit suivre bon mais néanmoins quelle
mesure coercitive faut-il prendre
puisqu'on voit que c'est bien ça l'un
des sujets qui montent et que beaucoup
estiment que l'index senior prévu par le
gouvernement c'est pas suffisant on va
voir aussi des des contrats spécifiques
qui peuvent être mis sur la table
notamment dans les passations de savoir
avec les nouvelles générations pour
maintenir le plus longtemps possible un
seigneur sur son lieu de travail et puis
ensuite
ils sont pas des mesures coercitives on
a entendu un certain nombre de membres
du gouvernement parler de mesures
coercitives les entreprises qui ne juger
il va falloir à un moment que tout le
monde se serre les coudes c'est-à-dire
que vous avez le monde de l'entreprise
les organisations patronales également
qui doivent pleinement prendre leur
place et que ça ne peut pas être que un
dialogue de sourds
pour être de mesure contraignantes non
moi je je pense que déjà la contrainte
c'est la dernière des solutions c'est
toujours la pire
le gouvernement peut
à un moment ou un autre mettre sur la
table des mesures contraignantes par
nature je ne les aime pas je préfère
être dans l'incitation que dans la
coercition ensuite effectivement si nous
voulons régler ce problème et que nous
ne pouvons passer que par la coercition
ce serait en soi forme d'échec disons le
très clairement c'est-à-dire que le
diable ne fonctionnerait pas mais je
crois que pour l'emploi des seigneurs
dans ce pays il va falloir effectivement
mettre le paquet et que demain sur la
loi pleine emploi il faudra prendre la
prise qui ne joue pas un jeu Marisol
Touraine qui a été à Laurine de la
dernière réforme des retraites elle a
été très critique sur cette réforme elle
dit notamment que c'est la première fois
qu'une réforme des retraites ne demande
aucun effort supplémentaire aux
entreprises est-ce que vous assumez de
demander des efforts à tous les Français
et à aucune entreprise dans cette
réforme vous savez je sais pas peut-être
que Madame Touraine aurait souhaité la
portée elle-même cette réforme mais que
elle est désolée de ne pas pouvoir être
encore au gouvernement comme elle a été
entre 2007
sur le fond je ne sais pas moi ce que je
sais c'est que lorsqu'on est aux
responsabilités et elle le sait c'est
difficile nous sommes aujourd'hui dans
dans une circonstance qui est
particulièrement complexe le
gouvernement a décidé je pense que cela
se voit d'essayer de stimuler depuis
2017 le monde de l'entreprise la
croissance économique et nous voyons que
malgré les difficultés inhérentes au
monde dans lequel nous vivons les
résultats économiques de la France sont
pas les plus mauvaises ou un sans faute
alors des années nous avons vu le
contraire ce que je vois c'est que ces
résultats ils sont obtenus parce que on
a cessé dans ce pays de sortir le coup
de matraque sur le monde de l'entreprise
sur le monde économique
ça peut être par exemple une petite
hausse des cotisations comme le propose
France à Bayrou ça peut être d'autres
choses comme le proposer François Bayon
puisque vous avez compris que cette
proposition ne sera pas dans la liasse
d'amendement qui a été déposé par le
groupe modem
alors selon les décomptes vous êtes le
groupe le plus frondeur de la majorité
il y aurait jusqu'à 6 députés qui
hésiteraient en tout cas à voter ce
texte comment vous l'expliquez alors que
votre votre chef lui défendait la
retraite jusqu'à pourquoi pas 67 ans
d'abord première chose je l'ai déjà dit
c'est à la fin du bal qu'on paye les
musiciens ça
justement en commission nous verrons au
moment du vote ce qui se passera et ça
c'est la première chose mais ce que vous
pouvez dire comme Aurore berger
qu'aucune voix de manquera dans votre
majorité moi je me permettrai pas parce
que je vais vous dire une chose je ne
connais pas encore l'issue des débats la
teneur des débats les modifications qui
peuvent être demain apporter et l'état
dans lequel pays se trouvera au moment
où on arrivera à la fin au terme de
cette rencontre que nous avons avec
nous-mêmes ici à l'Assemblée nationale
en tout cas c'est ce qu'il veut dans le
groupe
dans un groupe politique c'est qu'on
avait un certain nombre de valeurs nous
avons adhéré à des valeurs qui sont
celles d'être membre de la majorité
présidentielle et de continuer les
langues réforme qui prévaut depuis 2017
donc vous demandez à vos députés de
voter cette référence
à un groupe qui s'appelle horizon ça
veut dire que on n'est pas loin d'idées
portées par un homme qui s'appelle
Édouard Philippe et que sur ce point je
ne pense pas que Édouard Philippe fasse
partie des frondeurs donc si on veut
être contre on doit quitter horizon
ou la liberté j'ai pas je suis pas là
ici pour vous dire aujourd'hui comment
les choses vont se passer si on va
couper des têtes parce que je sais très
bien que c'est toujours ce qui agite un
petit peu le landernement on se dit
voilà si la personne
moi ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
j'ai dit très clairement à celles et
ceux qui sont membres de mon groupe que
lorsqu'on ne vote pas un texte financier
alors qu'on dit qu'on est dans la
majorité ça veut dire qu'on est dans
l'opposition on vous laisse c'est clair
je vous laisse comprendre ce que vous
voudrez bien comprendre on comprend
qu'il faudra quitter le groupe vous avez
besoin des voix des républicains pour
faire adopter ce texte puis si vous
manque une quarantaine de voix dans
votre majorité est-ce que vous pensez
que les républicains dont on pensait
qu'ils avaient topé finalement avec la
majorité est-ce que vous pensez qu'ils
vont vous faire défaut à un moment ou
est-ce que vous vous pensez que c'est 40
voix sont acquises moi je fais confiance
à ceux qui sont représentants désignés
des républicains le parti est représenté
par erikiotique et député ici même
l'impression qu'il tient les troupes et
le président
démarrer que ça également tenu un
discours clair à l'Assemblée nationale
et Bruno retaillod également au Sénat
maintenu et bien je pense que vous avez
confiance dans le vote des républicains
moi je vois pas pourquoi est-ce que
j'aurais pas confiance ce que je vois
c'est que depuis plusieurs
présidentielles ce parti politique
nous verrons nous verrons encore moi ce
que je remarque c'est que ils ont
soutenu il y a six mois une candidate à
la présidentielle qui proposait la
retraite à 65 ans et que il y a 5 ans
soutenait un candidat François Fillon
qui proposait aussi à une informe des
retraites particulièrement ambitieuse
après il y a une histoire des idées
politiques et des partis politiques
à eux de choisir s'il demeure dans cette
histoire ou si les en sorte en tout cas
si vous n'avez pas de majorité est-ce
que vous passez par 49-3 ou par
ordonnance ça c'est pas une question
qu'il faut poser à un président de
groupe parlementaire c'est le
gouvernement qui doit y répondre oui
mais sauf qu'aujourd'hui quand on fait
le décompte vous n'avez pas la majorité
et bien vous avez des possibilités qui
sont offertes par la Constitution vous
les avez rappelé vous avez un grand vous
l'avez utiliser moi je crois que il faut
laisser sa chance au débat comme une
dernière question vous êtes importante
de la commission d'enquête qui porte sur
les circonstances de la mort divan
Colonna vous demandez la levée du secret
défense dans cette affaire est-ce que
vous êtes optimiste pour l'obtenir
d'abord il appartient au gouvernement de
décider si oui ou non cette levée a été
effective Gérald Darmanin et Elisabeth
borne
qui peut aussi le demander puisque je
vous rappelle qu'il y a une instruction
criminelle qui a qui se déroule sur les
conditions de ce crime est-ce que vous
espérez obtenir avec la levée du secret
défense comme information que nous
souhaitons savoir c'est les éléments que
notre sécurité intérieure avait à sa
disposition concernant les activités de
Frank elonga B qui l'homme qui a tué il
va en Colonna lorsqu'il était un
Afghanistan puisque il a décidé de faire
le jihad et de partir à l'étranger pour
faire la guerre donc il aurait dû être
une grande dangerosité c'est un des
sujets particulièrement pregnants des
auditions que nous sommes en train de
faire avec le président de cette
transmission d'enquête parlementaire
merci beaucoup Brigitte et Tom Vincent
roux dans un instant juste sachez que
Emmanuel Macron vient de déclarer que
cette réforme des retraites elle avait
de la mobilisation est une réforme
indispensable
dans la droite ligne donc des
déclarations de Isabelle burnia est-ce
qu'il faut qu'il s'exprime Emmanuel
Macron il vient de le faire mais est-ce
qu'il faut qu'il soit face aux Français
dans une un exercice d'explication de
pédagogique comme on dit plus organisé
est-ce qu'il fait bref est-ce qu'il faut
qu'il descende dans l'arène le président
décidera le moment venu de sa
communication moi ce que je remarque
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a une première
ministre qui aux avant-poste avec la
ministre du Travail qui est également
particulièrement investi et puis si le
président jujutille un moment de
s'adresser à la nation et vous vous
dites bon voilà c'est la réforme du
Président c'est lui qui l'a vendu dans
sa campagne présidentielle il a
l'habitude du contact avec les Français
là il est répondu à une question dans
une conférence de presse au Pays-Bas
c'était très différent ce qui doit y
aller est-ce que ça vous semblerait
utile moi je crois que le président est
suffisamment intuitif pour déterminer le
moment où il voudra pas de conseils sur
ce plan-là merci beaucoup bonjour
Vincent roux merci d'être avec nous en
direct du figarolab c'est à VOUS Vincent
bonsoir Laurent
qui a été initié
demain c'est la fermeture d'un certain
nombre de mairie en solidarité selon
Fabien Roussel qui est l'initiateur du
mouvement avec les personnes qui vont
faire grève ou qui vont manifester
demain contre cette réforme des
retraites d'abord est-ce que vous
approuvez ce mouvement qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez est-ce que la mairie de
votre enfin vous n'êtes plus maire
d'Ajaccio mais est-ce que la mairie
d'Ajaccio restera ouvert demain je pense
qu'elle restera ouverte et si j'avais
été maire elle ne serait pas fermée ça
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire écoutez
vous savez la mairie c'est la maison
commune il
les services publics les mairies
dispensent qui sont fondamentaux et la
fermer même en gestes de solidarité je
ne pense pas que ce soit une très bonne
idée donc vous êtes allez-y est-ce que
vous approuvez par exemple
l'appel de Pierre Charron qui demande
que le gouvernement saisisse la justice
pour là en l'occurrence protester contre
la fermeture de la Mairie de Paris il
appelle la justice a fait respecter en
France la neutralité la continuité des
services publics est-ce que d'ailleurs
cette continuité des services publics et
cette neutralité sont vraiment bafoués
avec ces fermetures de mairie mais moi
j'aimerais bien savoir ce qu'on pense
les agents de la Ville de Paris
peut-être qu'il y en a certains qui
voudraient travailler et là à ce
moment-là le fait que l'exécutif
municipal décide de fermer ses portes va
à l'encontre de leurs droits et de leur
volonté
ils seront payés ça pose aussi une
question d'ailleurs de l'utilisation des
finances de la Mairie de Paris mais là
je pense qu'on pourrait faire toute une
émission là-dessus on
va pas avoir Vincent bonjour Yves très
vite directeur adjoint de la rédaction
du Figaro c'est ça merci bonsoir Laurent
alors
le président de horizon votre votre
groupe et votre partie votre mouvement
avait fait une entrée tonitruante dans
le débat des retraites en disant moi je
veux 67 ans comme âge légal de départ à
la retraite pierre depuis on l'entend
plus du tout il est où alors d'abord
puisque c'est à peu près la mille et
onième fois que on m'a parlé de ça
d'abord sur les 67 ans je rappelle les
éléments de contexte Edouard Philippe a
fait des comparaisons avec des pays qui
nous environnent qui sont nos voisins et
qui sont pratiquement tous à 67 ans à
savoir par exemple l'Italie ou encore
l'Allemagne ou la Belgique l'Espagne est
à 66 ans et à l'époque il avait dit si
on veut assurer la pérennité du système
pari partition si on ne veut pas baisser
les pensions si on ne veut pas augmenter
les cotisations il faudra travailler
plus c'est le discours du oui président
d'horizon où est-il écoutez moi je pense
qu'il va s'exprimer le contenu il le
fera de façon solennelle il le fera je
suis persuadé qu'il le fera et le fait
qu'on soit passé à 64 ans que la
première ministre est retenue cet âge-là
président de la République aussi est-ce
que il en a été fâché ou est-ce que ça
ne lui et ce qui ça lui convient ou pas
je rappelle que l'âge pivot qui était
celui de la réforme en 2019 c'était 64
ans donc en fait il y a une continuité
totale ensuite nous avons été je le
pense obligé de tenir compte d'un
certain nombre de que nous n'avions pas
à notre disposition lors de l'élection
présidentielle lesquelles et bien tout
simplement qu'on n'allait pas avoir une
majorité absolue que les temps sont
assez difficiles ça veut dire que avec
une majorité absolue ou pas si à 67 elle
débat aurait été deux facto un peu plus
simple en tout cas avec une majorité
absolue on se poserait pas les questions
que nous sommes en train de nous poser
sur
49-3 ça passe ou ça passe pas et
aujourd'hui nous avons une majorité
relative à l'Assemblée nationale avec un
pays qui se pose des questions notamment
sur son pouvoir d'achat sur vieillir en
France sur le rapport au travail et je
crois que ce qui fait la beauté de la
politique c'est quand on tient compte du
monde dans lequel on est est-ce que vous
trouvez que Edouard Philippe était assez
présent dans le débat national néanmoins
on dit que bon il s'occupe beaucoup de
littérature il a reçu l'auteur de du
match du Kremlin dans sa mairie
mais on ne trouve pas très actif et ni
très présent dans le débat contrairement
à Monsieur Bayrou par exemple qui est
l'autre pilier de la majorité
résidentiel chacun son style moi ce que
je remarque c'est que Édouard Philippe
est très connu des Français maintenant
depuis 5 ans il a été nommé Premier
ministre alors qu'il n'était pas
l'homme le plus connu de la vie
politique française qui a un lien qui
existe entre les Français et Edouard
Philippe qui a perdu malgré son départ
de Matignon en 2020 et que peut-être je
dis bien peut-être moi j'ai j'en ai de
la certitude que c'est ce style que les
Français aiment c'est à dire que c'est
pas avec Édouard Philippe qu'on va avoir
10 tweets dans la journée et un
commentaire sur chaque fait divers ou
sur chaque sujet la popularité vient de
la rareté en tout cas je pense qu'il
vient de la nuance d'accord et que la
nuance ça peut parfois aider dans un
monde où les gens voudraient un peu trop
simplifier les choses alors vous êtes
président du groupe à l'Assemblée
nationale horizon vous avez perdu si
vous me permettez un de vos militants
de vos députés à l'occasion d'une
partiel en Charente Monsieur Thomas
Meunier qui a été qui avait été élu de
justesse d'ailleurs en 2022 mais qu'il a
vient de perdre cette élection qui était
donc remise en question c'est parti
malheureusement de la vie politique moi
je veux c'est un signe
non c'est pas majorité présidentielle et
dans une situation un peu compliquée si
vous regardez les trois partiels la
majorité résiste bien par rapport à ce
qu'on aurait pu craindre vous avez un
premier tour où Thomas à réaliser une
meilleure performance qu'au mois de juin
ensuite vous avez eu des reports
probablement venant du rassemblement
national qui sont plus salés sur son
concurrent LFI par ailleurs on a gagné
un siège à Reims hier donc je me dis que
l'essence oui Renaissance mais bon
majorité à la majorité présidentielle et
horizon dont le maire de Reims c'est
l'un des membres réminants a soutenu et
la candidature de Madame donc voilà nous
sommes dans une équipe de majorité qui
aujourd'hui n'a pas perdu de siège je
regrette à titre personnel parce que
c'est mon ami mais également à titre
politique parce que je pense que c'était
un très bon élément de cette Assemblée
nationale la défaite de Thomas minet qui
laissera un vide alors vous avez un
objectif cette année en 2023 élection
sénatoriale après l'été au mois de
septembre
est-ce que vous allez pouvoir constituer
un groupe
[Applaudissements]
décidé d'investir qui que ce soit nous
sommes encore sur une réflexion
vous savez pour les élections
sénatoriales nous pouvons bien attendre
le printemps nous avons fort à faire il
y a des bruits selon lesquels vous êtes
en bisbille avec Renaissance
vous savez nous sommes dans des
négociations forcément
mondiale j'allais dire que Monsieur
Patriat et Monsieur Philippe ne
s'entendent pas je sais pas François
patriotateur du Président je sais pas si
c'est de notoriété mondiale en revanche
vous savez très bien que hier comme
aujourd'hui et voyez-vous comme demain à
chaque fois que vous arrivez en période
électorale vous avez négociation entre
différentes organisations c'est pas
forcément toujours très simple donc vous
confirmez que les discussions sont
difficiles
ça se passe toujours difficilement mais
regardez encore vous avez eu des
négociations avant les élections
législatives tout le monde sait qu'elles
sont apres rappelez-vous c'est très rare
les temps baignés du RP et l'UDF lorsque
vous aviez des négociations pour les
élections c'était pas facile finalement
ça ranger donc j'espère que on
s'arrangera
petite question très politique si le
groupe LR ou une majorité du groupe LR
ne votent pas la réforme des retraites
est-ce que d'après vous ici leur mort
c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure il
sera difficile d'expliquer à leur
militant qui a sont inscrits dans cette
famille politique une famille politique
qui depuis des années défunt la valeur
du travail et notamment inscrit dans son
programme une réforme du système des
retraites qui a réformé le système des
retraites avec Nicolas Sarkozy
d'expliquer à ces militants que au final
on fait capoter la réforme ça va être
difficile dernière autre question pardon
si cette réforme ne passe pas
mettons-nous dans les hypothèse du pire
pour vous si elle ne passe pas est-ce
que le chemin est compromis pour 2027
pour Édouard Philippe d'abord si cette
réforme ne passe pas le chemin est
compromis pour la pérennité de notre
système de retraite ça c'est la première
chose ensuite vous savez pour 2027
j'aime bien la longue vue mais il faut
de la porter et 2027 c'est loin c'est
très loin donc vous êtes comme Pierre
Dac je pense que c'est un long chemin
mais c'est compliqué pour qui en dehors
du système vous avez raison de le dire
mais si ça passe pas c'est ce qui se
passe c'est compliqué à un moment de se
projeter sur une stabilité même de notre
système par rapport aux réformes que
nous sommes d'accord
est-ce que une échec de cette réforme a
des conséquences politiques majeures on
parle de dissolution je pense pas que ce
soit forcément une très bonne idée de
remettre dans l'atmosphère cette
histoire de dissolution tous les quatre
matins je pense pas que ça amène de la
sérénité notamment dans l'Assemblée
nationale moi à titre personnel vous
savez la confrontation au suffrage
universel me fait pas forcément très
peur mais l'idée de la dissolution à
chaque fois qu'il va y avoir un examen
de texte je pense pas que ce soit
très habile non pas du tout
le président en dispose parce qu'il a
déjà dit que si jamais on s'opposait à
lui à l'Assemblée nationale il userait
de cette disposition la dernière fois
que ça a été utilisé je m'en souviens
c'était en 1997 les résultats ont pas
forcément été à la hauteur des attentes
de celui qu'il avait fait il paraît
merci beaucoup Yves créa et il avait
raison ivre de dire qu'on entend peu
Édouard Philippe vous nous dites qu'il
va prendre la parole hein j'en suis
pratiquement persuadé
vous nous dites qu'il va bientôt prendre
la parole il y en a un qui parle
beaucoup plus qu'Edouard Philippe dans
le débat public c'est Jean-Luc Mélenchon
et je voudrais vous soumettre une de ces
affirmations
à l'occasion de vœux à Villiers-le-Bel
les vœux d'un député Carlos billingo
voilà ce qu'il a dit récemment écoutez
nous avons dans notre pays la pire des
offenses je n'en fais pas une affaire
personnelle le premier milliardaire du
monde et français
il y en a pas un entre nous qui a trouvé
que c'était une bonne idée j'espère vous
avez pas dit à la maison waouh
le plus milliardaire du monde il est
français accumulé de l'argent et immoral
je le dis on m'a déjà reproché de
l'avoir dit mais je le dis puisque
qu'est-ce qui est accumulé ce qu'on a
pris aux autres
voilà donc deux affirmations l'une
concernant Bernard Arnault précisément
et l'autre sur le principe d'accumuler
des richesses quel est votre réaction à
ce type de discours qu'on entend de plus
en plus
d'abord qu'il est fidèle à lui-même
c'est pas la première fois que Monsieur
Mélenchon tient ce genre de propos
et deuxièmement il est cohérent il est
cohérent dans son incohérence parce que
je considère que nous avons besoin
d'avoir des gens qui a gagné leur vie
aussi nous avons besoin d'élite nous
avons besoin d'avoir des entreprises qui
réussissent nous avons besoin d'exporter
la connaissance française et moi je
j'avoue avoir un peu de mal avec ce
discours même si encore une fois je vous
le dis monsieur Mélenchon est cohérent
avec ce qu'il dit depuis de nombreuses
années nous avons dans le pays la pire
des offenses
j'en verrai d'autres si nous étions dans
un pays où comme dans certains
républiques que soutient Monsieur
Mélenchon les droits fondamentaux des
pas respectés je considérais à que ce
serait vraiment une offense est-ce que
pour finir parce que Monsieur dossier
nous a rejoint et on va lui donner la
parole dans quelques instants est-ce que
cette chasse aux milliardaires qu'on
entend de plus en plus quelque chose qui
qui traduit un mouvement profond en
France comment vous l'analysez ça a
toujours existé ça a toujours existé il
y a toujours eu des mouvements de fonds
qui visent à s'en prendre à certaines
classes de la population moi je dis que
quand on exerce des responsabilités
publiques il faut faire attention à ce
qu'on dit il faut faire attention à ce
qu'on propose parce que parfois on est
dépassé par la base et ce qui m'inquiète
lorsque je vois les discours de très tôt
de Monsieur Mélenchon c'est qu'un jour
et bien on soit dans une guerre civile
dans ce pays ce sont des propos qui qui
sont des ferments de guerre civiles ce
sont des propos de division et moi je
suis plutôt pour les propos de
rassemblement
bonsoir Thomas dessus merci beaucoup
d'être là vous avez accepté tous les
deux de débattre et on vous en remercie
vous êtes sénateur Europe Écologie
l'hiver et vous avez choisi deux sujets
d'actualité de sujets de fonds pour
interpeller le remarque Angélil on
commence par la politique nucléaire par
exemple donc cette semaine normalement à
l'Assemblée vous allez voter les
conclusions de la commission Miss
paritaire sur les énergies renouvelables
nous au Sénat on a déjà
étudié le texte sur l'accélération des
projets nucléaires et dans au sein au
moment de l'étude de ce texte les
sénateurs de droite on fait sauter
l'objectif de réduction de la part du
nucléaire dans le mix énergétique
français qui devait atteindre les 50% en
2035 et ce plafond a sauté moi
j'aimerais bien savoir ce que vous chez
Horizon vous pensez de de de cette
diversification du mix énergétique
finalement a été enterré au Sénat la
semaine il y a 15 jours moi je je serai
sur ce qui avait été annoncé du discours
de Belfort par le Président de la
République d'abord il y a un objectif
c'est plus de sobriété l'autre c'est le
développement du nucléaire parce que
nous avons pris du retard sur le
développement du nucléaire et le
troisième c'est le développement des
énergies renouvelables vous avez parlé
de la loi dit ENR qui a été voté au
Sénat et à l'Assemblée nationale c'est
je dirais à première étage de la fusée
et vous avez effectivement un texte que
vous n'avez pas voté si mes souvenirs
sont exacts faites partie des 16
sénateurs qui n'ont pas voté contre les
239 qui est à l'ont voté au Sénat
concernant le nucléaire c'est un débat
que nous allons avoir à l'Assemblée
nationale je sais que il provoquera
certainement de la contradiction et des
débats de fonds si on est en retard sur
le nucléaire c'est en partie parce que
la filière nucléaire n'est plus à jour
et n'arrive pas à produire ce qu'elle le
promet c'est-à-dire que elle a promis
des EPR qu'il faut Corée Du fonctionner
en Finlande il fonctionne pas à
Flamanville il a 10 ans de retard il
fonctionne toujours pas ce qu'on a vendu
aux anglais ça prend déjà du retard les
opère en Chine on connaisse un centre de
déconvenu donc en fait la filière se met
en terre elle-même parce qu'elle promet
des choses qu'on ne pourra pas atteindre
et les EP R2 qu'on nous promet aussi
c'est des belles promesses mais qui
globalement on ne sait toujours pas
faire mais cette fois-ci on va aller on
ne sait on va multiplier les fiascos en
série on va en faire 6 d'un coup donc
pourquoi s'entêter dans cette filière là
alors que en face sur les Indiens
renouvelables on avance plus vite c'est
moins cher on sait faire on sait on sait
déroulé il y a des pays qui investissent
massivement dans les énergies là qui
arrivent à couvrir énormément de leurs
besoins avec les énergies renouvelables
et aujourd'hui la filière nucléaire est
en panne si je suis votre raisonnement
vous êtes favorable à ce qui a été fait
dans d'autres pays la Suisse l'Allemagne
l'Italie c'est-à-dire arrêter le
nucléaire de manière ferme et définitive
en sortir pour actuellement vu le mix
énergétique français on n'a pas le choix
de garder nos centrales actuels les
faire tourner comme on peut parce que
globalement on a un problème c'est
qu'elle tourne mal et qu'elle subisse
assemble davary en raison en revanche il
faut qu'on accélère sur les énergies
renouvelables aujourd'hui si on a été
cet été en galère de d'énergie c'est
parce qu'on avait 30 réacteurs en carafe
et qu'on avait aucune production
énergétique en dehors des énergies
nucléaires et donc on était nous-mêmes
piégé dans notre mix énergétique donc
aujourd'hui on a besoin de développer
massivement les on-r et donc les
investissements au lieu de les mettre
sur des projets dont on ne sait pas si
ils fonctionneront un jour puisque ce
n'est toujours pas le cas autant les
mettre tout de suite sur des énergies
qui fonctionnent ce que je remarque
c'est que
vous allez laisser poursuivre mais les
pays dont je vous parlais ils sont
totalement dépendants au gaz russe donc
c'est aussi un enjeu de souveraineté ce
que je pense c'est que la France
mais aussi les enjeux de filières la
France s'est caractérisée pendant des
décennies par ces performances en
matière d'énergie nucléaire vous avez
raison de dire que nous avons à un
moment marqué le pas pour des raisons
exogènes des accidents nucléaires qui
avaient changé la donne je pense
notamment à Tchernobyl dans les années
80 mais également des problèmes
endogènes liés aux entreprises qui sont
dans ce secteur aujourd'hui je fais
partie de ceux qui considèrent que il
n'y a pas d'avenir pour notre
souveraineté énergétique sans le
nucléaire c'est là où nous avons un vrai
un point de différence par contre là où
nous pouvons nous rejoindre c'est sur la
montée en puissance des énergies
renouvelables vous savez je suis issu
d'un territoire qui est particulièrement
attaché à la beauté de ces paysages et à
la préservation de son environnement
nous avons de quoi faire par exemple pas
encore sans matière hydraulique en
matière solaire et je fais partie de
ceux qui militent et j'ai déposé des
amendements en ce sens d'ailleurs dans
le projet de loi MNR et donc
malheureusement pas été adopté pour
pouvoir permettre l'installation
d'avantage de d'énergie renouvelable
donc je crois que le mix doit prévoir
une présence des énergies de
renouvelables mais également une
présence du nucléaire qui pour moi est
un jeu de souveraineté nationale tu as
demandé des investissements un mur
d'investissement auquel on ne pourra pas
faire face et ça c'est l'argent magique
on la connaît on a encore vu des
déclarations si on peut peut-être aller
sur nos objectifs en termes d'énergie
renouvelables on les a pas atteints
parce que on n'a pas assez investi et
globalement on a atteint aucun nos
objectifs écologiques c'est ce qui a
Emmanuel Macron a rappelé il y a deux
jours dans son intervention sur les
réseaux sociaux en expliquant que on
allait de voir doubler nos efforts alors
la question de qui fait l'effort ça n'a
pas été abordé c'était pour revenir à
votre conversation sur les milliardaires
mais on doit devoir doublé l'effort
parce que sur le mandat précédent on n'a
pas atteint notre objectif et l'une des
personnes qui a été une manette lors du
mandat précédent c'est votre président
Édouard Philippe qui a été un mauvais
élève en terme d'écologie durant son
mandat parce que c'est après que les
plus grosses lois écolo sont passées
donc moi j'aimerais bien savoir quelle
est votre position sur le bilan
écologique de d'Édouard Philippe sous le
monde apprécient qui nous a pas permis
de d'éteindre nos objectifs ceux qu'on
avait fixé il y a 7 ans au moment de
l'accord de Paris vous savez Edouard
Philippe a été après mise pendant trois
ans et il a défini un certain nombre de
politiques publiques qui sont menées
également après le moment où il a quitté
Matignon il s'avère que vous a pas
échappé que le début du quinquennat
Macron entre 2017 et 2020 a beaucoup été
tourné à sur l'économie avec des lois
très importantes qui ont été votées il y
a eu quelques crises à gérer soit dit en
passant une crise de gilet jaune et une
pandémie mondiale ensuite Édouard
Philippe est retourné à la mairie du
Havre après trois ans de bons et loyaux
services et aujourd'hui je vous dirai
qu'il y a une feuille de route qui a été
fixée par le Président de la République
a été annoncé d'ailleurs par Christophe
Béchu qui est très proche d'Édouard
Philippe comme vous le savez et qui est
mon ami avec la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments privés et publics avec des
sommes très importantes qui ont été
mises sur la table par le gouvernement
avec les verdissements des moyens de
transport mais également avec des
accompagnements en direction des
collectivités territoriales qui seront
aussi massif pour pouvoir permettre
d'être comme vous le dites parmi les
bons élèves ensuite ce que je dirais
c'est que la France en matière de
protection de l'environnement et en
matière de classement n'est pas le
bonnet d'âne du monde bien au contraire
et que nous sommes plutôt fiers des
efforts qui ont été réalisés ces
dernières années la France se fixer des
objectifs on doit d'ici 2030 donc dans 7
ans diminuer nos émissions de 50%, c'est
énorme vous dites que des
investissements qui ont été faits en
réalité ils ne sont pas à la hauteur
c'est le Haut Conseil pour le climat qui
le dit c'est d'autres agences qui le
disent sur la rénovation thermique il
faudrait monter à 8 à 10 milliards
d'investissements ce qui avait été
acquis par certains amendements écolo
qui étaient passés lors du budget qui
ont c'est raboter au 49-3 donc on voit
bien que le gouvernement même quand on
peut le avoir une majorité à l'Assemblée
pour débloquer des moyens il les enlève
donc on est sur un double discours
permanent des belles annonces des belles
annonces comme on a eu il y a deux jours
même si on n'est pas complètement dupe
sur la réalité concrète de ces annonces
mais là on perd on paye encore une le
syndrome de l'écologie plus tard vous
l'avez dit il y a eu des crises on a
d'abord privilégié l'économie comme s'il
fallait opposer les deux d'ailleurs
c'est pas notre conception des choses et
puis on a toujours repoussé repoussé les
décisions et donc aujourd'hui bah
l'écologie plus tard ce sera l'écologie
trop tard comme on dit et effectivement
on en est plus à la hauteur des moyens
qu'on doit mettre je prends un exemple
sur les collectivités moi je suis
sénateur donc élu par un certain nombre
d'élus et qui ont des difficultés à
boucler leur budget notamment sur les
politiques énergétiques notamment sur
les politiques de d'investissement dans
la transition dans la rénovation on sait
qu'on doit doubler l'investissement des
collectivités dans les années qui
viennent sur ces questions là mais le
gouvernement notamment Bruno Le Maire
veut récupérer du budget des
collectivités veut leur couper toute
autonomie fiscale avec la suppression de
la CVA par exemple donc on voit bien que
le gouvernement sur les collectivités
coupe tous les moyens possibles pour
investir donc c'est quoi votre question
qu'est-ce qu'on fait quand on doit
investir et que d'un autre côté on a un
ministre de du budget qui nous dit il
faut serrer la ceinture mais pour le
climat par exemple 30 milliards d'euros
avec le plan France relance avec la
relance verte 30 milliards d'euros avec
le plan France 2035 ça fait 60 et une
augmentation des moyens consacrés à la
transition écologique et énergétique
dans le budget 2023 19 milliards d'euros
pour accélérer la décarbonation de nos
modes de vie mais aussi pour protéger
des Français contre la hausse des prix
de l'énergie vous pouvez pas dire à la
lecture de ces chiffres il y a 79
milliards d'euros investis pour essayer
d'aller vers ce que vous espérez c'est à
dire une décarbonations c'est à dire le
verdissement de notre économie et
également le fait de léguer aux
générations futur une situation
meilleure que celle que nous vivons on
est largement en dessous de ce qu'il
faut faire même avec vos 80 milliards
monsieur farando président de la SNCF a
expliqué si on veut décarboner notamment
nos modes de déplacement il faut
investir dans le train et pas n'importe
quel train les petits lignes les petites
lignes notamment dans les territoires
qui irriguent les sous-préfecture qui
rient toutes les les petits villages et
villes de notre pays et monsieur
farandon nous a expliqué qu'il fallait
100 milliards pour investir dans ces
dans la rénovation de ces lignes là
aujourd'hui ils ne sont pas là pire que
ça on continue d'investir dans les
projets routiers plus de 18 milliards
investis sur les projets routiers sauf
qu'en matière d'écologie mais en même
temps ça ne fonctionne pas donc comment
on fait quand on investit à la fois sur
des projets routiers qui vont
contribuer à l'accélération du du
dérèglement climatique et en même temps
qu'on a pas les moyens d'investir sur
les petites lignes de train ce que je
pense c'est que aujourd'hui
ces projets routiers ils sont aussi là
pour favoriser la facilité de vie pour
des millions de nos concitoyens qui sont
particulièrement inquiets lorsqu'on on
dit que on va tout fermer vous voyez
bien d'ailleurs ce qui se passe autour
de Paris attendre de décision qui ont
été prises qui rendent les gens Maboul
les gens n'arrivent plus à rentrer dans
Paris et vous voyez bien que dans les
grandes métropoles de ce pays
aujourd'hui il commence à avoir une
rupture entre les métropolitains et les
gens qui habitent autour c'est-à-dire
vous voyez bien qu'aujourd'hui l'accès
l'accès des centres-villes l'accès à des
villes par les moyens de locomotion que
nous connaissons deviennent plus
compliquées moi je suis pas pour une
écologie castratrice et punitive une
écologie qui monte les Français les uns
contre les autres vous avez bien vu
qu'aussi de la crise des gilets jaunes a
été à un moment provoqué par ce type de
ressenti chez des millions de nos
concitoyens donc je crois que
aujourd'hui le gouvernement est sur la
bonne voie en étant équilibré sur ses
propositions en mettant des moyens parce
qu'il faut de l'argent et en étant pas
dans une vision punitive et castratrice
de fracturation entre les populations
effectivement à l'extérieur des grandes
villes et à cause de politique
aux commandes des grandes métropoles en
France qui doivent gérer notamment ce
qu'on appelle les zones affaiblissement
c'est pas une mesure des écologistes
c'est une mesure du gouvernement
précédent qui mais bien sûr en fait si
on met on met juste les jaunes
affaiblissement
sans aider les collectivités à permettre
aux citoyens de rentrer dans les villes
autrement qu'en voiture thermique on y
arrivera pas vous allez vous portez
avant
de la faible émission sans les moyens
donner aux collectivités
la solution
n'existaient pas moi ce que je remarque
aujourd'hui c'est que le combat pour
l'écologie moi je le respecte et le
combat que vous portez et que l'histoire
de votre partie politique porte il est
respectable ce que je remarque en
revanche c'est que dans la manière que
vous avez ici en France à Europe
Écologie l'hiver d'applica ça tombe de
choses je trouve que vous êtes beaucoup
moins pragmatique de chaque que certains
de nos voisins qui eux sont dans des
gouvernements sont aujourd'hui aux
responsabilités et que dans la manière
que vous avez notamment de gérer soit à
la tête de municipalité soit dans des
majorités municipales comme c'est le cas
à la ville de Paris il vous créez des
politiques publiques que vous avez des
fractures ben oui je suis discuter avec
n'importe quel banlieusard qui vit
autour de Paris on arrive plus il y a
des banlieue aussi monsieur oui bien sûr
oui
je constate simplement que vous avez
aujourd'hui des décalages des décalages
flagrant entre ce que vivent des
millions de Français qui vivent dans ce
qu'on appelle le périurbain qui vivent
dans des communes qui ne sont pas de
grandes métropoles c'est aussi un groupe
écologiste au Sénat c'est qu'un centre
d'élus écologique dans tous les
territoires français bien sûr non mais
j'ai pas dit le contraire
bien sûr avec des avec des mères et la
plupart
aussi écologistes dans les vos meilleurs
scores sont plutôt réalisés on va quand
même pas se sont dirigés par des
écologistes il y a quand même des villes
de banlieue qui sont dirigées par les
écoles donc il faut arrêter les
caricatures ce que je remarque
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il y a une fracture
qui parfois est créée entre une vision
je le rappelle castratrice et un peu je
dirais totalitaire et une vision
le premier ministrement des gilets
jaunes il était écologiste où il était
chez Horizon il avait pris des mesures
il avait il avait pris des mesures à la
base qui était destiné à à limir la à
limiter la facture carbone et vous avez
vu ce que ça a donné il y a une
acceptabilité aujourd'hui dans le pays
qui est très faible je tiens à le dire
je le ressens je pense que vous le
ressentez vous aussi et que il faut
faire preuve de modération et il faut
faire preuve je pense de d'humilité par
rapport à ces questions là parce que il
y a des fractures dans le pays et ces
fractures là je n'aimerais pas qu'elle
devienne trop grande dernière question
monsieur non mais c'est toujours la
cette situation de on veut on nous
propose beaucoup de choses sans mettre
l'investissement derrière moi j'ai
toujours je reste extrêmement mitigé par
rapport à vos réponses sur
l'investissement qu'il faudrait mettre
sur les collectivités notamment pour
avec cette fracture là on ne peut pas
dire il faut aller modérément vers
l'écologie l'écologie c'est l'obligation
moyen et de résultats et là pour
l'instant ni l'un ni l'autre ne sont
atteint moi je considère que les
projections qui sont les nôtres
aujourd'hui les programmes qui sont les
nôtres sont particulièrement ambitieux
et c'est là qui nous sommes sur un des
accords mais je n'entendais je
n'entendais pas moins de par d’acidator
écologiste devenir porter la
contradiction je pense que vous avez
quand même en partage une chose c'est
que il faut agir sur ce sujet comme sur
d'autres qu'aujourd'hui la bataille pour
le climat c'est une vraie guerre que
nous devons mener de génération
civilisationnelles j'en suis totalement
convaincu mais parfois nous n'avons pas
la même manière de mener cette guerre et
pas les mêmes méthodes c'est aussi
simple que cela c'est dessus vous vous
allez manifester demain et non parce que
sinon il y a beaucoup de textes qui
passent demain après-midi je vais être
en séance notamment
vous seriez allé manifester la première
semaine de mobilisation et comment vous
sentez cette réforme le gouvernement va
faire voter sa réforme et à l'Assemblée
les efforts sur les plus fragiles et que
ça les met en colère ils ont raison
des fautes communication du gouvernement
vous reconnaissez qui a eu des erreurs
dans l'explication dans la présentation
de la réforme
et une fois des contre-vérités n'en
feront pas des vérités c'est que vous
avez ce que le sénateur vient de dire
c'est pas des efforts sur les plus
fragiles au contraire nous nous voulons
assurer la pérennité d'un système que
les plus fragiles pourront dans les plus
fragiles pour en bénéficier à l'avenir
c'est ça aussi le sens de cette réforme
et je crois que plus de solidarité avec
plus de travail c'est le sens de cette
réforme que les Français ne perçoivent
pas du tout cette réforme comme ça dans
une grande proportion
oui Laurent marqueur de génie la semaine
dernière 15 femmes djihadistes et 32
enfants ont été rapatriés en France ils
étaient détenus au Kurdistan
est-ce que vous approuvez cette cette
mesure
l'avocat Thibault de montbrayage qui est
président du cercle de réflexion sur la
sécurité intérieure dit dans le Figaro
aujourd'hui que la France a en réalité
n'a pas les moyens de surveiller c'est
djihadistes et revenant
la France elle a une obligation puisque
vous avez des décisions de justice au
niveau international qui oblige la
France à faire un certain nombre de
choses puisque ces femmes sont
françaises et que leurs enfants doivent
être recueillis par le pays de leur
maman et d'abord c'est une obligation à
droite internationale ensuite il y a des
enfants il
il doit y avoir une différence entre les
deux naturellement mais en revanche ce
que je voulais vous dire pour répondre
[Musique]
le niveau des djihadistes ou des
terroristes à baisser et bien je ne peux
que m'en réjouir et j'espère que ça
continuera comme ça
voilà vous êtes rassurés Vincent j'ai en
tout cas eu la réponse à ma question la
réponse de Laurent marcorcher une
dernière question le remarque en génie
le conflit en Ukraine beaucoup de débats
autour de livraison de chars qui ont été
confirmées et une inquiétude sur
l'escalade d'ailleurs la Une du Figaro
la semaine dernière Philippe Gilly avait
signé un article sur ce sujet mais il
n'est pas le seul
pierre Lelouch aussi l'ancien député
s'inquiète d'une escalade qui pourrait
amener à un engrenage est-ce que vous
partagez cette inquiétude je me suis
rendu en Ukraine à la fin de l'année
dernière compagnie d'Édouard Philippe et
d'autres élus
je crois que ce qui se passe là-bas
très important
très important pour le modèle de société
dans lequel nous voulons vivre vous avez
un pays souverain qui a été attaqué qui
aujourd'hui souffre et que nous devons
soutenir c'est une question
liée à une certaine idée que nous avons
de la vie une certaine idée que nous
avons de la démocratie et du respect de
du droit international
l'Ukraine doit exactement dans les
proportions qu'elle demande sans
s'inquiéter du risque d'escalade
possible en un mot je pense qu'il faut
que les pays de l'Union européenne se
mettent d'accord pour aider ensemble
l'Ukraine dans les conditions que
fixeront les pays de l'Union européenne
ça a été le but des discussions qui ont
eu lieu notamment à Paris il y a
quelques jours entre chancelier allemand
et le président de la République il faut
aider l'Ukraine il faut le faire en
concertation il faut le faire en
concertation mais il faut le faire merci
beaucoup elle a aussi le sujet de toute
une émission merci beaucoup Thomas
Dossou d'avoir accepté aussi le débat
avec Laurent Marc Angeli à très vite et
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine bien
sûr à 19h30 non d'ailleurs pas la
semaine prochaine parce que priorité à
l'hémicycle et au débat sur la réforme
des retraites on se retrouvera très
prochainement pour auditions publiques
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]